alors je vous montre quand même quelques
images vous allez vous rendre compte de
ce que c'était à l'époque Camille
Lellouche voilà qui clash les jurés de
la Nouvelle Star à l'époque lorsqu'elle
a passé le casting je vais enchaîner
quelques images je voudrais vraiment ce
que c'était que l'époque et ensuite on
en parle regardez
la September
[Musique]
Camille mais t'as pas tu as pas chanter
tu as déboulés c'est pas facile non plus
hein
mais qu'est-ce que vous a amené de 9 à 9
mais ouais c'est wagons de chanteurs qui
nous juste qui nous endorment je sais
pas chanter devant un public je le fais
tout le temps je demande des gens ok
bien vous ne m'écoutez pas vous avez
raison ce sera pas pour cette fois-ci
Camille ok une prochaine fois je n'ai
pas enrhumé comme ça
et donc regardez derrière ce qu'elle en
a dit quelques années après
le concept c'est quand même d'être très
méchant je trouve avec tout le monde et
en plus ce qu'on voit quand ils font ils
rigolent je vous jure je viens de Vitry
et je te promets qu'ils ont pas fait ça
devant moi c'est-à-dire que tu me vois
même petite comme ça c'est du montage il
y a personne qui fait jamais de la vie
franchement j'étais triste et surtout
j'étais vraiment la plus 9h du matin
j'avais 39 de fièvre là ça se voit pas
du tout il y a la preuve là physique et
je vais jamais vomi trois fois dans un
seau ça on le dit pas aussi et je t'ai
dégoûté et en fait quand je dis c'est
bon ça sert à rien de continuer je vais
arrêter de parler je suis énervé dans le
raide il dit attention elle est très
énervée j'entends ça j'ai rien non mais
c'est bon il voulait que je pleure en
fait et c'était dur franchement c'est
dur je vous en passe encore un ou deux
pour que vous ayez des idées là c'était
évidemment manucure sur Cindy Sander et
après on enchaînera sur manukian qui
désigne martial martial à Star Academy
qui chante quand même très bien regardez
parle-moi de super qui te battons deux
fois
j'avais l'impression d'assister on m'a
fait une séance de torture je suis
attaché je vous écoute chanter et je
dois avouer et là j'avoue tout ce que
vous voulez que j'avoue parce que je
veux juste que vous arrêtiez de chanter
c'est terrible parce que je suis en
train de vous dire mais je vous sentez
bien mais alors vous avez tous les
petits ringards
qui n'existe plus depuis longtemps quoi
vous sortez comme au 20e siècle que tu
viens de nous proposer pour moi c'est
pas digne d'une demi-finale de la
Nouvelle Star là tu vas avec toute une
énergie tu jettes dans la foule mais
[__] cette chanson mon pote elle l'a
entendu 200000 fois on était au karaoké
de
Saint-Julien-Molin-Molette là ce soir et
j'avais plus de plaisir qu'on regarde
plus de plaisir à regarder les breaks de
batterie de Loïc bon Dieu qui a écouté
qu'est-ce que tu nous proposes là dessus
rien rien et en plus tu chantes faux et
en plus et en plus tu chantes faux
ça c'était à l'époque de Bastia dit je
ne devrais plus d'émission parce que on
peut plus dire la vérité sa vérité ce
qui considérait de sa vérité dire
parfois quelqu'un par exemple arrête la
chanson c'est pas ton métier c'est quand
même très très dur qu'est-ce que ça vous
évoque vous est-ce que par exemple avec
cette nouvelle star vous avez trouvé
trop lisse c'est ce que vous aimiez
cette époque là vous pouvez dire les
choses ou maintenant ça vous choque moi
je préfère oui dire que carrément
tu as mal chanté tu as mal dansé dire on
peut plus rien dire mais la société est
devenue lisse c'est pas l'émission C'est
pas c'est pas la télévision la société
on a déjà des écoles on peut plus rien
dire aux enfants vous comprenez que
certains puissent dire par exemple il y
avait la phrase de Madonna qui avait dit
ne jamais prendre nom pour un pour une
réponse que c'est pas parce que manucure
te dit tu es un mauvais chanteur que
c'est forcément vrai et que vous pouvez
aussi briser une carrière juste Amel
Bent il est là pour vous dire pour dire
ça et puis il faut que par ailleurs la
personne soit épaulée vous allez dire
oui il mannequin mais c'est son avis tu
peux aller voir ailleurs c'est arrivé
avec Beja il a dit à une danseuse arrêt
de la danse avec 20 ans plus tard cette
fille elle rencontre elle dit Monsieur
Béjart j'étais danseuse et j'ai arrêté
la danse à cause de vous vous m'aviez
dit que et me dit mais pourquoi vous
m'avez écouté
c'est génial et Yanis est-ce que cette
année après j'arrive à vous parce que je
vous adore est-ce que cette année tu as
senti effectivement c'était plus lisse
j'ai passé l'extrait de l'or ballon tu
sais qui s'en est pris un petit peu
on s'en souvient leur ballon qui est
effectivement fait une petite réflexion
je sais plus ce qu'elle dit à un élève à
Julien qu'est-ce qu'elle lui dit
qui se
produit
les briefings il y avait à côté le
directeur et elle pouvait plus rien dire
est-ce que tu es d'accord que c'est même
toi tu t'es un peu réfréné tu disais pas
tout ce que tu pensais alors faux c'est
juste que c'était édité parce qu'en
direct justement tout le monde avait un
peu peur de moi parce que c'était du
direct et là c'est on pouvait pas nous
couper
mais faut moi j'ai dit j'ai toujours dit
ce que je pensais et il y a juste même
pas 50% de ce que j'ai dit qui est passé
à l'antenne parce que c'était un peu
trop dur pendant les évaluations mais
moi j'ai toujours quand Julien par
exemple que j'aime beaucoup refuse de
danser en talon il y a plein de mômes
qui regardent et qui peuvent se dire ça
peut être pris un peu pour de
l'homophobie on t'a pas entendu mais
parce que ça c'était pas un problème
pour moi le bizarrement on s'attendait
si c'est pas un problème parce que moi
j'ai jamais fait ça et j'ai jamais
ramené les talons pour forcer qui que ce
soit d'accord et en fait je trouve que
justement il y a rien de pire
c'est pas comme ça que tu fais accepter
quelque chose à quelqu'un le forçant tu
es obligé de mettre donc en fait mais
qu'est-ce que tu as coupé on a coupé par
exemple que tu as dit
ah ben je sais pas mais tellement enfin
moi je disais vraiment tout ce que je
pensais donc est-ce que c'était des
trucs par exemple faire un peu de poids
tu pourras jamais danser des trucs comme
ça non c'était mon opinion
professionnelle sur les évalues
après je sais que par exemple ils ont
pas voulu montrer qui est
il fallait que ce soit on est tous
copains tous amis entre entre prof déjà
donc il y avait pas il y a pas une seule
petite querelle qui a été voilà ça a été
coupée
alors je m'entendais très très bien avec
leur balance avec quelqu'un d'autre que
je m'entendais ah c'était l'autre parce
qu'on m'avait dit c'était qui non mais
c'est j'ai eu des accords avec Adeline
voilà Adeline tu es désaccord avec
Adeline Ghislaine alors vous c'est
hallucinant parce que vous avez été
remplacer ensuite par une autre femme
mais c'est des bisounours mais les cinq
premières saisons de Top Chef avec tout
le talent que vous avez d'abord moi j'ai
eu deux ressentiments celui qu'au milieu
de tous ces hommes un peu comme une
femme policière fallait mettre deux
coups de RAM pour justifier votre talent
parce que vous étiez une femme et le
deuxième on vous appelez la méchante
mais en dehors de l'émission et et dans
l'émission est-ce que ça vous a d'abord
est-ce que ça vous ça vous a blessé et
est-ce que vous est-ce que pour vous
c'était c'était nécessaire c'était ce
qu'il fallait faire vous n'avez pas eu
de regret
c'était peut-être pas nécessaire mais
j'en avais rien à faire en fait
quand je voyais ou quand on les ça
m'arrivait voilà la vilaine Guylaine la
vilaine Ghislaine la méchante Ghislaine
la sorcière c'est facilement s'appelle
les sorcières
mais en fait je m'en foutais mais il y a
beaucoup de choses qui étaient coupées
dans ce que vous disiez chaque fois vous
avez parlé je crois un Canadien un truc
comme ça et vous l'avez dit vous êtes
approché vous aviez goûté vous avez dit
mais c'est c'est la merde un truc comme
ça c'est la merde
faire voir parce que ça vaut rien voilà
va te faire voir parce que ça vaut rien
bon ça a été coupé
ça a été coupé mais est-ce que vous
trouvez que cette manière de faire elle
est nécessaire comme le ponce Oscar et
c'est comme ça qu'on fait avancer les
gens ou au contraire faut dire à la TF1
c'est très très bon c'est excellent mais
on regardera pas ton plat non moi je
suis toujours partie du principe qu'en
fait nous on a eu la chance de faire les
les premiers à
format qui avait été acheté par M6 on
était les premiers à faire ce genre
d'émission donc c'est très très excitant
et puis c'est très formateur même pour
nous et les gens que nous avions devant
nous étaient forcément des
professionnels travailler dans des
restaurants ou à vélo restaurant et donc
je vois pas pourquoi je ne pourrais pas
leur dire écoute ça j'estime que il y a
des gens qui vont venir chez toi pour
payer pour manger ça je suis pas
d'accord alors j'ai une autre question
pourquoi scanner qui se donne une image
odieuse dans Cauchemar en Cuisine
j'adore cette émission c'est normal
parce que c'est qui fait rugbyman mais
vous quand vous faites une réflexion
désagréable vous êtes méchante mais non
mais pour être belle c'est pas pareil il
fait le même le même rôle que le format
anglais oui mais donc il a repris est-ce
que c'était ce qui plaisait si on met
quelqu'un très moutonneux ça va pas
marcher mais vous êtes parti comme au
bout de cinq saisons c'est qu'il y a une
raison on est parti avec ça à 4 à 12 ans
ce qui a une raison les autres sont
restés on nous a pas donné raison non
mais c'est vous qui êtes parti oh c'est
tout blanc
qui avait
Lignac
elle est beaucoup plus à l'américaine
mais
ça vous pourrez maternelle et ça vous
vous avez dit un peu c'est pas c'est pas
en allemand
en fait vous pensez qu'il faut être
comme dans une cuisine et dans une
cuisine on va être honnête sa gueule
dans une cuisine on est toujours un peu
un peu sur les dents quand on goûte
quelque chose quand même à nous à nos
cuisiniers a fait on le juge ce qui est
normal parce qu'après ça va être pris
par un client et
je pense qu'il faut savoir dire les
choses alors Oscar ce que c'est
intéressant quand même c'est que la Star
Ac si on est honnête là il y a eu cette
semaine c'est un petit peu court
normalement c'est 13 semaines on doit
former une star en 13 semaines on sait
tous que sur 1000 personnes s'il y a une
star c'est exceptionnel sinon les autres
bah pardon ça sera je sais pas des
choristes de ce que oui mais être une
star c'est quelque chose qu'on a ou
qu'on a pas donc est-ce que justement
vous pensez que il faut au contraire
être très très dur avec eux parce que ce
métier va l'être
avec ceux qui ont du talent qui on avait
cette saison par exemple il faut je
saurais pas le nommé comme ça parce que
je regardais une fois oui une fois sur
deux mais
alors juste comme vous avez regardé
qu'une fois sur deux qui vous avez
retenu c'est important comme ça de cette
génération là de la sarac je me souviens
pas son nom une fille
avait beaucoup de cheveux
là j'ai retenu Enola j'ai dit cette
figue et puis il y a pas qu'une carrière
il y a plusieurs formes de cahiers des
carrière plus discrète ils sont tout
aussi denses et importantes donc mais je
pense qu'on est dans un dans un monde et
dans un pays où la rigueur ne plus de
place ça c'est vrai j'avais 20 ans donc
il y a encore hier encore
j'avais 40 ans vous voyez et j'ai créé
une petite troupe comme ça on faisait
tout je faisais tous les décors je me
demandais des vieux draps et tout mais
j'avais une exigence j'allais dire
militaire parce qu'il fallait qu'ils
allaient qu'ils arrivent à l'heure non
j'ai rien d'allemand je suis italien
espagnol gitan que voilà et les
comédiens français ils se sont réunis un
jour parce que j'étais trop exigeant il
me dit voilà on a quelque chose à te
dire c'est pas parce que tu as vécu un
dictature
[Rires]
j'ai une question le professeur
de la rigueur on va vous êtes de toute
façon vous faites partie de ces gens
Oscar quand vous entrez quelque part on
vous regarde vous l'avez vous l'avez pas
yanisla évidemment ne parle pas mais
c'est vrai que les gens ils l'ont ou pas
j'ai une question quand même cette année
le prof de la Star Ac pardon le prof de
de théâtre pourquoi tu me dis pardon moi
je
c'est super je suis pas prêt bah
d'autant que tu es peut-être d'accord il
a été inexistant au même moment
même au montage il était inexistant et
il a même donné l'idée que ça n'a aucun
intérêt et le théâtre pour devenir une
star fais-moi une tomate trop mûre oh
fais-moi un arbre et même pour vous on
se disait mais c'est ça ils ont ils ont
un peu pour moi un fantiniser
ridiculiser le cours de théâtre ce que
vous avez ce sentiment est-ce que c'est
important le cours de théâtre dans la
Star Ac la dernière fois vous avez dit
quelque chose comme ça ça m'avait blessé
tu dis quoi ah oui j'avais dit que les
ah pardon David
on sait à à Marseille
vous les avez euh
vous avez coché les amis Nelly non mais
ces gens-là ont fait
d'accord d'abord du théâtre après du
Martin gramme pour pouvoir avoir le
droit de prendre un micro-ondes non
c'est pas moi qui l'avais dit je me suis
très bien alors ça pour le coup
je mets très très bien c'était Sophie il
faut c'était Sophie il faut un fusible
c'était Sophie qui avait dit un prof de
théâtre c'est souvent un acteur raté et
j'avais pas aimé ce que tu avais dit
forcément j'avais reprises
non mais j'ai entendu c'était minable
c'était minable
et puis il avait cette espèce d'énergie
qui donnait aux élèves et effectivement
le prof d'après c'est un peu plus Yanis
bébé déjà j'aime beaucoup pierre c'est
vraiment j'aime beaucoup pierre c'est
pas un métier
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
timide et au final je pense qu'il est
encore un petit peu plus timide voilà
je trouve qu'il est timide encore au
final mais
l'impression qu'il était gêné d'être là
presque il est timide moi je sais que si
on me demande très honnêtement je dirais
qui est au final je l'ai trouvé un petit
mythe voilà mais c'était peut-être pas
un homme de télé et lui c'est il vient
de faire les caméras c'est très
compliqué c'est demande un peu
différents
c'est ça et je pense que j'ai un
souvenir de Pierre j'aurais peut-être
pas dire ça mais bon c'est fait
maintenant j'ai un souvenir de Pierre
juste dans les loges de la Star Ac
d'accord sur les prime on a toutes les
célébrités invitées bah moi j'étais la
première loge donc il passe moi ma porte
est ouverte il y a de la musique il y a
souvent Madonna il y a des plumes
voilà et
et en général les célébrités passées me
dis bonjour et ça va Amel ça va ça va et
lui il était souvent dans le couloir un
petit peu
donc c'est vrai que je me suis aperçu
qu'il était moins
à l'aise au pied d'ailleurs et
d'ailleurs avant de passer un extrait je
vous montre avant de passer est-ce que
Ghislaine justement c'est très différent
moi j'ai connu des gens qui étaient très
très drôle dans un dîner et une fois
devant une caméra il donne plus rien
est-ce que la caméra voilà vous ça vous
a plutôt
merci merci
trop longtemps il a réfléchi trop
longtemps oh là là trop de mal j'ai
entendu c'est ça moi aussi donc vous
l'aimez pas vous dire tout à l'heure
pourquoi vous l'aimez pas et regarde
justement regardez justement comment
était considéré considérait ça du
harcèlement aujourd'hui ce serait du
harcèlement sur les élèves regardez
chez moi et j'ai entendu tout un tas
d'insultes timon confirmé juste déjà ton
ton je suis désolé pour tes parents ou
quoi mets ton manque d'éducation parce
que là c'est ton manque de respect mais
tu peux te marrer et tu peux prendre ton
erreur et si tu continues je vais te
virer de mon cours et c'est normal que
j'ai eu cette réaction alors c'est
normal c'est normal d'insulter les gens
mais sachant que ce sont des
professionnels de ce milieu et qu'on
respecte les instruments moi je suis
rentré j'ai vu oui oui oui oui oui oui
oui oui oui oui oui
merci beaucoup
je ne me fais pas insulter à 38 ans sur
la 5e saison de la Star Academy c'est
clair
alors attendez est-ce que est-ce que ça
tu pourrais faire ça mais alors non
c'est d'accord on peut on ne moi j'étais
déjà considéré comme trop trop grande
gueule alors que j'ai jamais je suis
jamais allé jusque-là donc est-ce que ça
touche pas la question c'est ce qu'on
peut c'est est-ce que ça te choque ce
que tu moi ça me choque c'est fini les
amis ça me choque pas après là je pense
que c'est aussi quelque chose qui est
pris qui est sorti du contexte donc il
faudrait voir le le enfin je pense que
c'est trop facile de montrer un petit
extrait comme ça
elle était brutale pleurer pendant les
visions moi personne elle me choquait ni
elle ni personne me choquait à l'époque
et moi moi je mets très honnête ça me
manque la télé de l'époque mais ça me
fait voilà un moment c'est ça qui est
intéressant exactement que tu pourrais
pas le faire
Oscar est-ce que dans la question des
chroniqueurs et puis après j'ai une
question pour
Oscar Sisto qui déjà c'est bizarre cette
haine avec Raphaël profondément
c'était si populaire c'est parce qu'il
est le seul à penser que le monde est en
très dur il faut y préparer les jeunes
et que ça sert effectivement à rien
d'être un bisounours je pense que c'est
pour ça qu'il est aussi fermé
c'est aussi des créateurs de Redon droit
bien sûr et il vient visiblement les
aider vraiment à créer leur business là
sont des artistes qui sont appelés
normalement dire des grands artistes
donc faut être dur avec vous tu as tout
compris c'est que parler à un même de 16
ans et à quelqu'un de 40 c'est des amis
ça fait une heure que ça part dans les
couloirs et tout s'il y a une émission
concurrente vous me le dites
oui parler les enfants de 16 ans c'est
pas la même chose ils sont beaucoup plus
fragiles beaucoup plus c'est des éponges
donc on peut les on peut les abîmer
beaucoup plus
ouais après moi je perso je la danse il
y a pas grand chose dans la vie où je
peux dire ça je connais je sais de quoi
je parle la danse je sais de quoi je
parle d'accord on dit dans la danse ma
mère est prof de danse je suis prof de
danse donc moi j'ai pas peur de dire mon
avis de dire ce que je pense de
conseiller voilà mais après juste pour
le fun et après une question
foie gras est-ce que tu as vraiment le
sentiment que ça c'est un pigeon qui est
farci avec du chaud et du foie gras non
c'est pas c'est pas c'est pas la classe
version classique quoi j'ai revisité
demander un pigeon farci avec du choix
du foie gras le chef voilà ce qu'on
demande
je ne sais pas
on est d'accord je ne sais pas
quelqu'un d'honnête on vous propose
d'aller sur la nouvelle star cette année
vous y allez je ne sais pas
oui